مسلسل اخبار اهلا بكم قتلت قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي شابين فلسطينيين في عمليات
اقتحام ومواجهات في الضفه الغربيه ففي
بلده قباطيه بجنين قتلت قوه اسرائيليه
خاصه شابا فلسطينيا اثناء اقتحامها البلده
ماده الاندلاع مواجهات
وفي مخيم قلنديا بالقدس قتلت قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فلسطينيا ثالثا خلال اقتحامه
بها جنود الاحتلال في بلده البلده القديمه
بنابلسه قال الامين العام للامم المتحده
ان توسيع اسرائيل للمستوطنات وهدممها
للمنازل وتنفيذها لعمليه الاخلاق يؤدي الى
اثاره الغضب ولياس
قالت رساله الدفاع البلا روسيه ان لجنه
العسكريه روسيه بقياده قائد القوات البريه
زارت بيلاروسيا وتفقدت الوحدات العسكريه
الروسيه ضمن القوات الاقليميه المشتركه في
ميادين لتدريب وذلك قبل ايام من انطلاق
مناورات روسيه بلا روسيه مشتركه من جانبه
قال المتحدث باسم قياده القوات الجويه
على الحدود مع بيلاروسيا تحسبا لاي تطورته
اضفنا روسيا نشرت تجهيزات عسكريه تكتيكيه
في بلا روسيا تشكل تهديدا لبلاده
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بيد انه يتعامل
بجديه مع الوثائق السريه التي عثر عليها
في منزله وفي مكتب تابع له في واشنطن وضحا
بيضا ان البيت الابيض سيتعاون مع المراجعه
التي تجريها وزاره العدل بشان تلك الوثائق
من جديد قال وزير العدل الامريكي انه عينه
خاصه للتحقيق في اكتشافه وثائق سريه في
منزل الرئيس اضاف ان التحقيق سيتم مع اي
شخص او كيا قد يكون انتهك القانون في هذه
القضيه
بدوره قال رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكيين
على الكونجرس اجراء تحقيق بشان العثور على
وثائق سريه في مقرات الرئيس واتامل
الاداره الحاليه بالتعامل مع القانون
بمكيا لين حسب تعبيره
التقى مدير وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه وليامبرس في العاصمه الليبيه
رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد
دبيبه وتوقعت مصادر الجزيره يلتقي برزا
لواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر في بنغازي وان
يبحث الطرفين العلاقات الثنائيه ووجود قوه
فاجنر الروسيه في وسط وجنوب ليبيا
قال المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا عبد الله
باتيل ان المصالحه في ليبيا لن تكتمل الا
بحكومه موحده ونظام موحد وكذبتني على ان
الامم المتحده تدعم المصالحه الوطنيه
بوصفها مشروعا حاسما فيتامين السلام
والاستقرار
موجز الى اللقاء